la ciudad de portland aquí en oregón en
el oeste de los eeuu ha sido de forma
ininterrumpida el epicentro de la
tensión desde que empezaban las
revueltas en el país y es que las
estructuras de movimientos antifascistas
están muy bien organizadas en este punto
del país y han mostrado confrontación a
las fuerzas del orden de forma constante
pero bien estos días hemos tenido
presencia de grupos de supremacistas
blancos los proud voice han organizado
un acto al que han hecho gala pues de su
patriotismo y exaltación de la libertad
la libertad por ejemplo de portar armas
y esto lo vemos a menudo en este tipo de
actos pero bien aquí importan la
repercusión que ha tenido ha organizado
una contraprotesta del movimiento
antifascista del movimiento de las vidas
negras importante y hemos visto una vez
más la división en una sociedad
americana que se enfrenta en noviembre
unas elecciones presidenciales en la que
este tema precisamente es plano es clave
la cuestión de la ley el orden de la que
hace gala el presidente donald trump y
también de la injusticia racial que
sería la bandera que se apropia los
demócratas con joe biden
en cualquier caso hemos visto que forlán
sigue demostrando que es foto de la
noticia aquí en orejo